Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
We finally got a full-blown crossover this
is going to be my flash episode eight video.
Just careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet.
Let's see who's really the fastest.
So many comic book things in this episode
it was so wonderful and what about that Hall
of Justice.
They even lit it up at night just so that
you would focus on it, super friends unite
so.
Just a quick reminder there is a flash ring
giveaway that's going on right now.
That's right I brought the flash rings back
to the giveaway all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video.
Make sure you turn alerts on so you don't
miss anything let's do top 10 WTF and comic
book Easter eggs, so number 10 that final
scene from Supergirl they literally just like
took a scene from the flash contacted on the
end of Supergirl.
So is kind of a WTF, but I understand why
they didn't like they're still trying to logistically
fit Supergirl into the CW universe just because
behind the scenes is so complicated.
So I think the next year it will be a little
more integrated you will see more Supergirl
characters come in, for whatever the crossovers
can be, but the other big reason is that the
dominators are only invading Earth one but
they do explain the car is earth is 38 so
confirmed 38 the 38 doesn't seem like an Easter
egg to me right now because it doesn't refer
to any specific Supergirl stuff like Justice
league number 38 is in a Supergirl story the
flash number 38 is in a Supergirl story so
they might have some other hidden relevance
behind that 38 number.
But they did explain that the dominators of
Supergirl's universe would come back in the
back half of the season so these dominators
are Justin Barry and Oliver's universe which
kind of explains why it's only three way crossover
but it would've been cool to see the flash
about was cyborg Superman either way number
nine kid flash is getting faster and faster,
they just want to get them ready.
I think for the back half of the season.
Even though Cisco gets really pissed off.
They do so in a like don't tell them about
the suit.
So Wally will end up in that suit sooner rather
than later.
Speaking of which number eight Wally save
late in the game they had the storyline in
the episode that felt a little disingenuous
like irises like don't goad nobody tell them
that is awesome, everybody tell him that he
sucks even HR is like nope one Wally asked
them to train in the first time the second
time he relents, but even if Wally didn't
have powers he would still want to help out
I've I felt like this was like the weirdest
storyline in the episode don't tell Wally
he's awesome but he does help out.
It's a great takedown it's like a really simple
seat like you he helps out calls himself kid
flash and they gets taken up by Supergirl.
So he'll probably be back by the midseason
finale definitely by episode 10 when they
were all happy about that like we want to
kid flash back in the game.
Like this whole early-season of the flash
this Wally storyline has been drug out way
too much, but number seven aliens.
You know something out of a Ridley Scott nightmare.
I like the alien shoutout.
So the dominators invade and they learn from
Lila that this happened in the 1950s, but
the weird part of this is that the government
wants to handle it now it's not just Argus,
it's like the larger government that Argus
is a part of.
So Lila learns a little bit of the politicking,
but the president who is totally down to go
after the dominators gets you going to select
is itself a mind control storyline, but number
six flash isn't going to set things out.
Of course is not can assist things out so
they immediately cut to Star city like the
way they cut that edit where Oliver and Diggle
are chasing down vigilante if you have been
watching arrow this season.
He is one of the few villains on the show
now the Oliver's going after so Barry saves
them in the exact same way that he grabbed
the boomerangs from the first arrow flash
crossover they were actually couple references
and moments in this episode they call back
to that first one.
Like when Supergirl got mind control you're
not the first super here to get my control
like Barry did during flash versus arrow number
five they go to meet at a giant warehouse
that Barry just happens to have Thea says
you should do something with this but is like
an empty warehouse.
But then when they show the exterior it's
the Hall of Justice that they been putting
in the posterior promos in the Hall of Justice
is actually from the super friends cartoon
is where the Justice league headquarters are
so you to call in the super friends you can
call them TV Justice league it's much closer
to TV Justice league, but this is them like
full on doing it especially when they lit
it up at night so that also kind of reminded
me of HR's plan to turn star labs into a museum
like he was getting ready to pitch them when
the episode started, so that might also be
leading to the flash Museum they could just
combine the Hall of Justice with the flash
Museum because Barry sought when he traveled
back to save his mother in season one.
So eventually we have to get the flash Museum,
it's the Hall of Justice that's the new thing
we never thought that we were going to get.
So now that building existed.
Just imagine how the gonna use it next year
by the time we get to next year.
The also pry be a lot cooler stuff inside
there to they'll introduce each other the
legends arrived Diggle has his funny joke
moment you know the reason I don't take drugs
is because I'm worried I'll see weird stuff
like he threw up.
When Barry say to, so Diggle always has the
greatest reactions when weird stuff happens
but number four really big deal Barry's future
message is revealed the future flash cannot
be trusted for some reason causes like some
other big flashpoint change I think what they
meant to say.
They were little confusing about the way they
explain the war in the future.
I've gone back in time change things.
My understanding is that future Barry was
just explaining flashpoint the first flashpoint
the one that we saw happen on the flash to
rip hunter.
But this is older Barry and it also ties up
with the future newspaper flash vanishes in
crisis.
So now they brought back the flash newspaper
we haven't seen it in a while.
Iris West is in the author anymore, so there
are changes it just reflects the changes,
because of flashpoint, now Barry is in the
shit with the rest of the team Diggle is pissed
when he learns out about baby Sara now being
baby Jon.
I mean he's happy that his son exists, but
knowing that he had a daughter Barry just
change that.
Just completely sucks.
So if you like most of the teams reactions
to bury our justify.
They just wanted to create conflict so that
Barry would not go get emceed so that he could
save them later you can argue the logic of
their decisions.
But I feel like it's okay to be mad at Barry,
but Cisco did have that funny line reset apparently
now it's illegal to be mad at Barry number
three team flash versus Supergirl she just
laughs at all of their attacks like they tickle
her just completely remind you how invincible
she is compared to the others, so they might
bring the kryptonite ring in at some point
like Batman has the kryptonite ring in case
Superman ever goes nuts, so given more team
ups I would be surprised if Oliver finds a
way to make a kryptonite ring Barry feels
like he be too hopeful for something like
that like all my friend Cara she would never
do something to hurt me Oliver is the pessimistic
one he plans for the future.
So if anybody Scania kryptonite ring it would
be Oliver but that almost reminds me like
talking about rings of doing the flash ring
giveaway.
Cisco also tells the atom that he wants to
upgrade his suit, but is like later after
were done with this so if you got the atom
suit look kind of bogus if you didn't like
it in season one there going to make it way
cooler now.
So number two is Oliver and Barry versus the
team like an evil Justice league team up this
is as close to crime syndicate as I think
were gonna get for little while.
So Oliver Barry versus the crime syndicate.
Barry takes down a bunch of the aerial ones
with the lightning throw Oliver takes down
the mealy fighters makes sense then Wally
comes and helps take them out, and I love
the way flash took out the mind control device
by phasing Supergirl through him or essentially
he faced, so that she just ran right through
him the number one of course is them getting
beamed up into a dominators ship setting the
stage for the matrix like Arrow 100th episode
so that will explain the dreamlike state that
there and then I'll be in these pods.
I don't know how much of the episode.
They're going to spend in that dream, but
it's there hundredth episode so that big speech
that Barry gave to Oliver it was a really
awesome speech about how he's not a God, it's
not his fault the time changes, everybody
makes choices they change the timeline, but
when he said I would do anything to be able
to go back and change what happened to my
mother I felt so powerless.
So helpless.
Of course their setting that up for the arrow
episode, so they're totally gonna pay off
all that Oliver stuff like he explains how
his father killed himself in the other passenger
in the life raft so that Oliver could survive
all that is going to be followed up on in
the air hundredth episode so even though.
This is just the first part of the crossover
they done a good job of setting things up
that they'll pay off in the next two episodes
but for those you asking about future flash
stuff, so they were talking about the war.
I think they'll follow up on that it'll have
something to do with the savitar storyline,
so like each of the shows will take little
bits from this big crossover.
And it'll in form what's happening with their
storylines like Sara talks about not being
able to go back in time to save Laurel the
gonna follow up with that on legends.
Obviously arrow has all the hundredth episode
stuff in that will spin into Laurel stuff
as well, but for those you asking what that
future warriors, you could think of that as
future flash from the comics who just a size
that he can't be trusted to be is to go back
in time to kill himself.
Obviously that's not can happen on the TV
show it is meant to be that the worst possible
thing that could ever happen to them.
So like, Oliver said that people's choices
always change the future that's going to have
to happen on the flash like there can have
to find a way to change what's happening.
This season, to make a better future, so it's
always fun when you know that things are going
to complete shed okay what we know where were
ending up so we have to try to avoid that.
Now let me know what was your favorite moment
from the episode if you like Oliver and Barry
versus the team was probably my favorite they
open the episode with that.
So naturally it was like the biggest part
of the episode listed this way everybody leave
a like if you want to see a future crossover
versus like a crime syndicate for them to
actually do something like that but I do feel
like in the future season.
They might do Manhunters something like big
enough like war world Mongol to merit the
need for all these people to team up.
It has to be someone big someone that Barry
couldn't just take down himself using his
speed force powers to get height for Arrow
100th episode tomorrow deathstroke is going
to lay the smack down I'm so excited about
deathstroke, there's so much other stuff happening
in the episode to I mean if you're really
big fan of black canary arrow stuff in the
comics there can be doing a lot of that stuff
the really like deathstroke like all the people
that we haven't seen in forever sing Oliver's
father sing a couple other people we haven't
seen in a while I'm expecting Tommy, but you
pretty much every big cast member they've
ever had on arrow is supposed to be on.
I don't know about Roy though I haven't heard
anything about him guest starring haven't
seen him in any the promos.
So he would be the big surprise like if Roy
showed up was can happen is a post another
bonus video tomorrow morning I'll post a.
Rick and Morty video and then Arrow 100th
episode so there should be three videos but
if I don't think I'm in a get that Rick and
Morty video out.
I'll just let you guys know when I post that
first one what you guys wait for that to post
you can click here for my part one video that
explains what's going on this week what to
watch out for and you can click here for my
game of thrones season 7 teaser trailer.
So thank you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight!